so fans of the of the old Android
browser will be disappointed to hear
that it's not in the latest version of
Android anymore it's the Chrome is good
yeah great yeah
the default browser is now is now chrome
in 4.4 but not only that but the the
webview that's used by native
applications that's that's now Chrome as
well you know you can make native
applications using a mixture of you know
the best of native and mix that with the
best of the web but what is the the best
way to do that in and the answers I
believe are going to vomit out of the
mouths of our next speaker are you ready
to go I hope so yeah excellent okay
welcome our next speaker it's Matt gaunt
thank you Ron wow what an like an
entrance into a talk vomiting out of my
mouth
thank you Jake so yeah this session is
gonna be about building mobile apps with
the brand-new chrome webview My name is
Matthew gaunt if my clicker would work
there we go I'm a developer advocate
from the London office generally there
seems to be this trend of having stupid
photos of yourself if you ever seen Paul
Kinlan or pull Louis doing a
presentation yeah I don't know what this
face is I wish it didn't exist so I have
to publicize it apparently before I
start giving this talk I have to give
like a disclaimer I feel like the minute
you start talking about bringing web
technologies into a native stack there's
instantly kind of a flame war I don't
want to go into that but ultimately I am
a native developer before I joined
Google I largely focused on Android but
I did I asked back Barry nokia cute and
towards kind of the end when I was
working at that company we were doing a
lot of stuff with bringing web
technologies into our native apps we
were using JavaScript as the backend and
then as we started moving more and more
forward we kind of got to this point
where some companies they just they
couldn't do native apps things like
gambling you're not allowed in the app
stores with that and our designers were
kind of excited by this point because at
that point it was like well cool html5
css3 this this is awesome and seeing
them where they've had years of
experience doing
and all these different apps they just
ran with html5 and css3 and for me I I
loved what they were doing the biggest
problem I had was it's just like well
you're still in the web if you want a
presence in the App Store which many
people did how do you bring this web
stack into an app because normally the
web views they kind of a bit rubbish and
that's why I was really excited because
if you didn't hear and Jake's kind of
announced it
we actually swapped out the chrome the
the Android webview with the chrome
webview so we've got m30 now in KitKat
which is awesome it means that we get
this kind of slightly disappointing
score at 284 and he gets bumped up to
four to four which is awesome and it's
not just the fact that we get html5 and
css3 features that we didn't have before
we've also got the v8 JavaScript engine
which is much faster than the older
webview but even the more important
thing is going to be the dev tools that
you all know and love when I question
always get is features that kind of come
with this so it means you get indexdb
requestanimationframe insanely important
when it comes to performance SVG filters
and effects Jake Archibald has done like
a fantastic blog post on SPG's and I've
seen a number of things come out of it
that are awesome WebSockets you may not
really think about this but I love this
for live reload like insanely a lot and
then there's more but I'm not going to
talk about them so for me when it comes
to the developing mobile web apps using
the webview it kind of comes down to
three different things as the workflow
which for me is really different between
native and web apps like I yeah I'm
going to go into in a minute native
features that's probably one of the main
reasons why you're using the webview in
an app is because you want access to
something more and then you've got
obviously the design I don't know if any
of you guys had some of the really early
Android devices but if you saw the
design of some of those apps they were
kind of cringy and I think one of the
major things that most of the mobile
platforms have done is they've done
design guidelines
the develops thing on okay cool I'll
follow these and produce beautiful apps
so how does that apply in this scenario
so let's start with workflow generally
if you see a native developer coding
they will do this cycle code compile
repeat you could arguably say that we
all do the same in the very very early
days where we sit there we'd write some
code in HTML CSS we go talk browser hit
refresh and that's our first web page
done but in the web we have live reload
and it's insanely helpful because you
just sit there you code away hit save
and then you'll you're done you just
watch the effects take just happen
before you so who here is familiar with
Gradle not Gradle grunt start with grunt
no ok so about 50% so grunt
is a JavaScript task runner so you can
basically pull in third-party modules
that basically will perform some action
for you so you can imagine you want
something where when you say start my
server it will just start the server for
you it will compile your sass your
minify your javascript your HTML and
just basically take care of a lot of
housekeeping for you so when you come to
native at the moment we've got Gradle
which is new in the Android studio and
Gradle is kind of similar in many
respects you pull in plugins that do a
particular task so one of the things
that I wanted to do was join these two
things together I didn't want to have to
sit there and have different workflows I
didn't want to compile and wait for this
stuff to happen so with the new webview
we can actually get a nice flow going so
if I show you what we've got to do so
I'm get away from this
No stop it there we go
so this is a standard build file so
we've got things like just the Android
tasks which the Android team have put
together in it it basically that is your
Android build step now you might notice
down here we have this notion of product
flavors now the way you can think of
product flavors the canonical example is
someone has a free and a paid app free
ad might pull in adverts the paid one
you don't get them in this scenario well
I want one that is gonna be a static
build I want all the HTML Javascript CSS
to be in the app and then the other one
I want to be able to do this this live
reload I want it to be just running off
of my machine so if I show you scenario
here well you need to see the actual
thing so here we've got two applications
one on the Left which is just a static
build and then we've got nother one on
the right which is my live server and
all things willing and the network
playing nice this will work yeah there
we go
so all I have to do it's just hit save
and that will go and update itself on
the other side
there we go now the really nice thing
with this is it's surprisingly simple
just to get set up you don't have to do
anything you you are essentially
defining this product flavor and then
you're switching out a URL there's
nothing else beyond that and the nice
thing with the static build is that when
I come to say I want you to build me a
brand new project down the bottom
there's just the small couple of tasks
and basically what we've got here is
this little beautiful piece of code here
is basically when Android studio goes
I'm gonna build your Android app now is
there anything you want me to do before
I do that it will say well actually I
want you to copy my web application and
then before it does that what you can
actually say is well before you copy my
web application could you actually you
know maybe build it and run it with
grunt and essentially that's what these
two steps here are doing and the really
simple little task that just say grunt
build it goes and performs that task and
afterwards it will copy over and give
you a brand new build of your
application so for me this was an
insanely useful workflow because I've
seen a number of called over
applications and the workflow with the
command line interface where you kind of
just say called over build or run
Android and it does an entire
compilation step so then once you start
combining this with dev tools which I'm
going to need to plug my phone in before
so the minute I plug in my device you
notice that in chrome inspect we start
seeing my device turn up with these two
blocks now basically what this
application is doing is displaying
webview side by side because the
performance is better for horizontal
scrolling well what's really nice is as
I start scrolling my device left and
right you'll notice that the blocks very
helpfully start moving backwards and
forwards as well so nice thing with this
is now not only you getting exactly the
same experience that you get on desktop
but you are getting the full feature so
there's the obvious example that I could
do where I can sit there and edit slides
but the main thing that I think is
slightly more impressive if I go in here
and start saying FPS meter and you can
start seeing there that we're getting a
similar sort of thing that we're used to
across varying browsers well for chrome
dev tools should I say which is insanely
powerful but what's even more impressive
is as I start going through when I start
wanting to combine different features
you'll realize that dev tools has
actually started coming much more much
much more useful this whole build step
process it still works with the old
webview there's no difference the main
thing is you can't get live reload
because of the lack of WebSockets so the
way that I can get around that is by
basically saying I'm going to add a
refresh button exactly the same that I
would do with basically swapping out the
URLs so yeah there is no dev tool
support unfortunately the old webview is
still going to exist is still not going
to have dev tools how many of you have
heard of Winery out of interest
surprisingly large number of hands I
feel sorry for you all it is a very very
simple way of basically debugging in
browsers that don't have remote
debugging you can get it
p.m. and just add in a script it's not
ideal but it does give you like at least
something and then there's J s hi bugger
now if you're using Cordova application
this is basically you can just have a
plugin that will give you access to dev
tools and basically what it does is it
rigs up the older webview in Android and
basically makes it appear in chrome
inspect and works with the chrome dev
tools so you start getting a wider
support of features that winery doesn't
have so we have our live reload which is
awesome so the next step is going to be
well how do I start adding features into
my web application not useful so there's
two main methods when it comes to using
the webview and integrating native
features if you want to inject
JavaScript into the webview there's this
method evaluate JavaScript and that's
just basically the same as what you'd do
if you were in a normal browser and you
put JavaScript colon inject whatever you
will to get stuff out of the webview so
from JavaScript to call out into native
code you have this method add JavaScript
interface now the way this works is you
have something similar to this method
here and basically a JavaScript
interface takes two methods this
notification bind object which is
something that I've written and it's a
really bare-bones JavaScript object and
I'll show you it in a minute and this
name notification interface and it's
this name that you will use from
JavaScript to access it so if I go into
dev tools of my device I can
let's darken stop it so if I go window
dot Notification interface this is where
it's been injected into the webview
itself and this is how the JavaScript
would access it so it's just a plain old
object and you don't get any more
information than that now if I go into
the notification bind object you notice
there's no extending no inheritance but
the important part is this method here
show notification and the annotation
just above it at JavaScript interface
now the reason for that annotation is
basically to say I want JavaScript to be
able to call this method it came in for
jellybean mr2 before that if you
essentially have to be a bit mindful
because before that technically
JavaScript could call random methods I'm
not intending it to so this method show
notification takes a string and a
message and the main idea behind this is
if I get rid of my beautiful FPS meter
so the idea with this is that when I
hear this show notification button which
you can just about see you'll notice
there's a little chrome icon that's just
appeared up on the top it just says
chrome dev summit you're awesome
so the really nice thing with what we've
got in dev tools is I don't actually
have to have the JavaScript be executing
these native methods I can do it
directly from here
and there is the new notification now
that's a really nice way of working
because if you've got essentially one
part of your team building the native
component and you're focusing on the
website and they kind of turn around
they go hey I've just done this this is
cool can you check this out you don't
need to be worrying about whether you've
got script to run this you can basically
just sit there and do it there and then
from dev tools the only thing you need
is the webview running in terms of the
old webview I keep on clicking this in
terms of the old webview there is no
evaluate JavaScript method so you have
to use load URL JavaScript : the main
reason you'd want to use evaluate
JavaScript rather than the old method in
the new webview is actually faster
because basically the webview is is
expecting JavaScript it's gonna pass it
slightly differently kind of think of it
as a fast path and the other one is
obviously the minute you start using
native features it needs to be pointed
out the fact that you're gonna be
running on different versions of Android
stuff comes and goes so you just need to
be aware of that like Android studio is
very good at just pointing these kind of
things out as well as that there's also
a webview samples that I've just put a
link down at the bottom for and that has
examples of doing all of this as well as
shimming out the loading of JavaScript
etc so we have a workflow where we've
got live reload working and we have
access to native features and we have
access to dev tools so now we've got a
nice environment where I can sit and
code in my text editor I can then debug
it with dev tools and it's quite a nice
flow we've got similar to what we'd have
on desktop so the next step is what
should we be concerned about when it
comes to design generally each native
platform on the other is going to have a
set of native components whether and
generally they range from the small
things like checkbox buttons
to the much larger composite views and
for me the biggest risk with Web Apps is
generally that they fall into that
uncanny valley approach of well I'm
going to imitate the native platform
because that's where I'm living that's
what I'm trying to do and generally I've
kind of go down the route of if you want
to have native components or native look
and fill then try and use the native
components and don't imitate them if you
can't use the native components and do
something different even if it's
something similar just don't try and
copy it straight out try and do the fact
that the reason you're using it is
because it's a nice UX generally the
main things I point out that I think Web
Apps are generally gonna use action bar
as well as tabs and realistically it's
dead simple to actually add this for
Android and iOS like you can imagine a
simple case where you can have something
similar on both platforms the view pager
this is essentially a way of having
fullscreen views either side and then
swipe from left and right that's what I
was using in dev tools where I had the
images moving in chrome inspect and then
the other common one is navigation
drawer if any of you have checked out
pull versus wait tracker he's got like a
similar thing and the main reason I
point this out is I think the Android
team have spent a lot of time ensuring
that certain paradigms are met with this
you'd be surprised the number of
different versions of the same thing
exist
so who here kind of feels like just
creating a button on the web is nice and
easy and this shouldn't really be any
kind of thought behind it everyone so
one of the common things I tend to find
when it comes to this is when I start
touching these buttons I just start
getting this weird blue state that comes
up over it so this one at the top is an
anchor tag the one of the bottom is just
a HTML button that gets weird orange
outline on the bottom one and I see this
come up time and time again and to be
honest depending on the design it can
either
blendin or it just really stands out so
I'm gonna change these buttons so to get
rid of this blue tap highlight color the
main thing you need is WebKit - tap
highlight color hit save and then if I
want to get rid of the orange outline as
well we just need to set outline to zero
go on update
so I know why
right this time of library logo so it's
just two simple things but now you can
see that the state just it just does
nothing which is exactly what we want
from that you just need to do don't know
state one active so the key here is just
the active state set background color
I'm gonna go for blue so come on now of
course
yep so grunt should be taking care of us
ass there we go so we've got state now
who things are done who can say what's
missing anyone so the trick here is if I
go and touch this button and hold it
I get that beautiful little nugget now I
won't say you should blanket disabled
users select because there's a number of
cases like if that was a phone number
copy and paste is kind of cool it's a
text button that I really wouldn't want
that to be there so the simple fix for
that is users select none so when that
updates there we go nothing now I don't
know about you guys but that kind of
makes me a bit sad the fact that I have
to disable one prefix thing one outline
and then implement something completely
different and then also handle the fact
that I don't want the user to copy and
paste it to basically match a native
button at the same time it kind of
sounds a bit laborious to pay this
amount of minut details or something but
you do it once you're there you're good
and you only do it for the components
that you have in your web app and
ultimately I want frameworks to start
just basically implementing exactly this
kind of same thing because it's it's
essentially really really small little
nuggets of things that I see a number of
developers do and it's quite a simple
fix and the other thing that I kind of
wanted to talk about was to kind of
reinforce this notion of not trying to
imitate native like we've all seen web
trends like it's kind of one of the
great things about the web in general if
someone comes up with this beautiful
design and then we start seeing other
designers be inspired by it and
producing similar kind of things and for
me native apps don't move in terms of
trends as fast as the web so why try and
imitate native why not just keep this
going but actually bring it to native
platforms for me this is what I want to
see Web Apps do take the things that
work and make sense and then bring them
into mobile apps and show native apps
the kind of things that the web is great
at so that's kind of what I wanted to
talk about was this notion of having a
nice build process where you can have
live reload you don't have to sit in
Android studio and constantly keep on
compiling you can have native features
using the inject JavaScript as well as a
JavaScript interface and then we've kind
of covered design and for me it's one of
those things that from those three
things it should be simple enough to
actually get going something that didn't
exist with the old webview you couldn't
do this so if you go away from this talk
not really remembering any of this talk
there's two things that I want you to
really remember the first one is this
uses SDK Android target SDK version
equals 19 now the reason for this is 19
is Android KitKat and if you set it to
anything lower than 19 you basically put
the webview into a compatibility mode so
to avoid any of the web applications
from breaking from jellybean to KitKat
we emulated some behavior that existed
in the old webview so things like target
density dpi it's been dead for a very
very long time but there are still apps
using it and kind of relying on it for
their UI so to rip it out with me maybe
breaking a load of apps unfortunately
though if you are following everything
this can still have adverse effects if
it's lingering around that you start
seeing differences between the two so
make sure you add target SDK version 19
the other thing is you will want to do
this web set set web contents debugging
enabled to true the main reason for this
is if you don't call this method you
won't have access to dev tools in the
webview it's basically
you don't have to leave it on you can
basically switch this on and off
depending on whether it's a debug build
of your app or whether it's a release
build but one way or another when you're
first starting out you're going to want
to use this so in terms of what the
future looks like for the webview the
old webview is still going to be
important one way or the other it's
still the predominant version like
jellybean is the predominant version of
Android devices so unfortunately you
still have to kind of support it unless
you're happy to go for KitKat on words
which I wouldn't blame you if you did
and I think at the moment updates are
still tied to Android releases with the
new webview and generally everyone in
the team wants this to move to auto
updating we kind of see it as kind of
the one thing that we really want to
change we just need to figure out how
we're going to do it because basically
the webview is part of the android
framework and nothing at the moment
changes itself so we're trying to figure
out how we can do it and the other thing
is the chrome apps team are actually
bringing in a lot of the chrome apps
api's to called over as plugins so it'll
be interesting to see what happens with
the usage of that if you've got a chrome
app already that you're relying on
native features that are coming in
through Chrome apps API you can now
start getting it on mobile so the three
talks I'd say go and check out perf
matters which is Tom and that they'll be
covering things that basically should
help you write 60 frames-per-second apps
for the webview Paul Kinlan will be
covering best UX patterns for the mobile
web and that's generally just the things
that you should be thinking about when
you're developing mobile web apps and
then Joe Marini is going to be covering
developed Chrome apps for desktop and
mobile so thank you everyone
I've got a set of links chrome Doc's
Android Doc's some samples and if you've
got a web application already out there
there's a migration doc which basically
covers a lot of the common gotchas when
you're moving from the old webview to
the new one so yeah thank you everyone